vous faites partie monsieur fellmann
d'une catégorie en voie d'extinction
rarissime ça me fait penser à jeu
longuet ministre de l'industrie en 86
qui disait mon espoir
ce sera de supprimer un jour le
ministère de l'industrie
bon c'est quand même une espèce rare la
singularité français c'est que les aides
aux entreprises d'une part soit elle
créer des effets d'aubaine
ça a été le cas sous mac rompt avec ce
que j'évoquais le cic eux ce sera le cas
aujourd'hui avec le plan de relance ou
ça se greffent aussi avec on l'a évoqué
tout à l'heure des pratiques
d'affairisme invraisemblable vous savez
que l'un des leviers publics pour aider
à l'investissement des entreprises bon
surmonter le choc c'est la banque
publique d'investissement la bpi est
l'apport de l'argent elle est supposée
les apporter notamment aux entreprises
moyennes pour les aider à investir et
préparer l'avenir
vous savez la dernière annonce là
aujourd'hui dans cadre du plan de
relance de la bpi
ils ont décidé de mobiliser je vous le
site à titre d'illustration 50 millions
d'euros pour qui monsieur xavier niel
qui est bien connue être un petit
entrepreneur qui manque d'argent pour
investir voilà c'est une blague
pas facile d'annoncer une vraie
information mais qui dit bien le mode de
ce capitalisme incestueux dans lequel
nous sommes où les gens sont à la fois
néolibéraux et sur un fonds de 2 voilà
deux systèmes à ses traits consanguins
système eassist incestueux entre la vie
des affaires et la vie politique
jean philippe feldman ce ferris notre
point d'accord avec monsieur peleman il
y ades et de l'affairisme soleil on est
en pleine affairisme monsieur mouche lui
même un traîneau de dinosaures il n'a
pas peut pas encore parce
qu'effectivement les libéraux sont assez
cons france je crois qu'il ya une erreur
parce que ça n'était pas monsieur
longuet de mémoire qui était ministre de
l'industrie en 1986 mais mon ami alain
maintenant c'est alain madelin qui avait
dit qu'effectivement je l'espère
je serai le dernier ministre de
l'industrie que vous pouvez de france
qu'on fait ça n'a pas été le cas
ce qui prouve bien qu'on n'est pas dans
un système libéral
[Musique]